[Music]
in 2016 I had the opportunity to study
in Europe specifically Dublin Ireland
experience was incredible because my
goal was always to work for the giant
tax companies
when I returned to Central America I
noted that there was a certain market
for this skills so I wanted to start a
consultancy firm but definitely the
world was paralyzed by the pandemic it
was not only July 2020 that I saw the
light at the end of the tunnel I
received a chance to start as a devops
engineer when the challenge progressed I
companied with continuous learning path
to improve my credibility not only with
my great team
but with our customers and that's why I
choose this time for University to
continue my professional education is to
get some credential with reputation I'm
sure that my Knowledge and Skills that
this program provides me are well
received anywhere in the world
maybe here in Latin America not only in
El Salvador we see as unreachable all
this kind of opportunities my motivation
is to leave a mark in everything I do to
be an inspiration for those who like me
face limitations to show them that the
gold is rather than the obstacle get out
of your comfort zones do not seek to be
employed instead seek to be employable
there is no better place to consolidate
this knowledge than this problem